it's must've been here for millions of
years and look at of the Rockies growing
around it I don't like this place
hey guys
holy Shh what think there's aliens in
this be quiet
this is real like are we really in this
place you like candy shop just just
breathe okay
would you explain it why there's
something here
[Music]
what's going on instead oh my god
we were all in it think plate we really
found this point is that
what's wrong
the answer to what is happening to you
is here new five are the Power Rangers
any other question probably more like
Iron Man or spider-man could you just
say something anything man for kids
occupation by underground whoa
pretty sure I'm a superhero what dog
sighs wait
okay cool
Power Rangers okay okay goes pretty
quick manual manual where the front out
of five you have to remember that in
today's train listen the important thing
is to wait for Zach seriously alright
ai-ai-ai-aight all right my bad my bad
let's follow me right
hey youtubers is Charlie so I had a
chance to see Power Rangers early this
is going to be my non-spoilery review if
you do to the channel I do Marvel DC
genres stuff every week be sure to
subscribe to get everything we are in
prime movie-going season blockbusters
are here so what I'm going to do is a
quick rundown of like who all these
characters are and even if you're only a
little bit familiar with Power Rangers
history you'll totally understand what's
going on here but like a lot of new
movies try to reimagine really big old
franchises they did some interesting
things with the characters backstories
like Zordon and Rita Repulsa and if
you're a longtime Power Rangers fan
you'll have a lot of fun with but if you
couldn't guess from all the trailers the
footage this is very Chronicle looking
so if you don't know what that movie is
it's just a story about a bunch of
teenagers in the real world people that
get picked on I'll cast that
mysteriously get powers in what happens
as a result of that some of them decide
to be heroes
some of them decide to be villains but
the cool thing that they do with the
Power Rangers movie is the way they work
in the idea of that Chronicle twist so
this is all about the origin story this
is the first human team that Zordon
himself in the context of this movie
universe has put together now you have
to assume that like all the other Power
Rangers series are totally valid but
because this is the first in a new line
of movies you have to assume this is
starting at the very beginning so the
series that it has the most in common
with is the first American run which is
actually where I started with the series
I didn't watch too much of the series
after that I watched all the way through
that first 1995 movie Mighty Morphin
Power Rangers who remembers that raise
your hand if you saw that in a movie
theater I was so excited about that when
it came out so I was really excited when
I heard about this I was interested to
see what they did with it they really
tried to gritty it up and marry that
Chronicle feel with classic Power
Rangers feel so like if you went back
and you watched the original series I
mean it feels super campy so they tried
to address that with the movie I thought
they did a pretty good job Chronicle was
a good movie but don't go into the movie
expecting it to all be like this bryan
cranston of course is amazing at
everything he does he does a great sword
on Bill Hader did a great job as alpha 5
and even though I thought Elizabeth
Banks was a weird choice for Rita
Repulsa
based on all the changes they made to
her backstory the way she fits into the
film it all totally works and remember
that this is meant to be the first film
in a new
franchise so depending on how it does
financially and I think it will do
pretty well you'll see another Power
Rangers moving in another couple of
years so if you're a really big fan of
that original Power Rangers team you can
just start picking villains based on the
progression of the classic series but
man for like the first half of this
movie
it is just so real-world and gritty like
they really want you to feel all their
problems in this small town that they
live in before they get to that fun
Power Ranger stuff the movie really does
come together once they get the Zords
they get their powers they start playing
around that's when it becomes a real
Power Rangers movie but I feel like they
spent a little too much time on teen
angst less time on big superhero action
stuff so I feel like the next movie will
correct that they did the backstories
now they can get to the fun stuff but
let me know in the comments like what is
your favorite Power Ranger series what's
your memory of it have you been watching
it recently the franchise's actually
jump hands a couple of times it used to
belong to Disney for a long time till
Haim Saban got it back and that's why
they're calling this movie sub ons Power
Rangers so after you see the movie or
after you watch the classic movie again
just let me know what you think of all
this in the comments but fun fact so
everybody knows about Super Sentai how
this is based on that the Power Rangers
series basically repurposes Japanese
television footage for all these big
action set pieces but there are over 101
Super Sentai different teams that they
put together in 24 different Power
Rangers teams so if you tried to rewatch
everything it would literally take you
forever they've been running a live
stream I think on Twitch for the last
week or so and they're still not even
halfway done with the series yet it's
crazy that's how much Power Rangers
there are they have almost as much Power
Rangers is there are Simpsons episodes
so at some point they'll do the Simpsons
thing where they just start a channel
all for Power Ranger stuff 24 hours a
day so be sure to check it out this
weekend it was a lot of fun I mean it's
no Logan Logan was a great film this was
a son popcorn film so just make sure you
know what you're getting when you go to
see it so what I'm going to do next is
is I have some iron fists that I'm going
to do I'll do an explainer for the
ending and then we have the new flash
episode I'll post that video after the
episode airs tonight where you wait for
that click here for brand new flash and
click here for my Iron Fist review thank
you so much for watching let's high-five
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]